No Freak bitches,
they've got to have two wings of the,
of the psych ward.
They're like one,
like they've got the standard issue
harmful to yourself or others,
you know,
like committed for the involuntary
psychiatric hold.
Then they've got the,
the something else,
the extraordinarily,
you know,
like,
uh,
the extraordinarily qualifying
individuals,
you know,
and the something else wing.
So it,
so they had me on the something else
swing and like,
whoa.
Yeah.
And like my roommate was like fucking
like hiding in the closet from like in
demons.
Oh Dude,
it was.
I mean,
I've been hearing voices for like a
couple of years,
but nothing like this guy voices say,
Oh,
do you see,
well you're the best,
your cell phone,
your
angels and demons,
you know,
like some of them would tell me like,
you're worthless.
He needed to die and I would be like
trying to suffocate myself to death,
you know?
Well,
yeah,
I mean not like with anything,
I'm just holding my breath.
That was the guy.
Well,
but that was the whole thing was I was
hearing voices because I was hopping so
much nitrous oxide.
And while,
um,
while you're doing ketamine,
while I was doing cocaine,
I never smoked this joint.
Just fucking relax.
You make me feel so much better about
myself.
I used to watch it watch intervention so
that I could feel better about myself.
I'm worried about your health more than
I'm worried about like you overdosing.
I'm worried your overall,
it's a slow deterioration of your fiber.
Like the stuff that keeps you together,
you're talking to me.
I'm fine now.
I feel like I just worked out for
talking to Steve.
I may have been when they said a sign
I'm in something else.
Award like people are not people.
One Guy,
I remember one guy like shit on the
fucking ground and was breakdancing and
it like tried to like.
I mean it sounds like I'm making it up.
I swear I'm not dude.
He was in,
his goal was to like smear it around
as much as he could.
And this is in the room with,
you know,
that was in the hallway.
It was another dude.
It's break dance.
You go to his own Shimmy.
It looked like his break dancing.
But he was like,
he took a shit and he's trying to smear
it around as much as he could and it
just looked like it was break dancing
and that's,
you know,
you're talking earlier about like how
our culture,
you know,
we repress all this really natural stuff
and make it a problem when it doesn't
need to be a problem.
I've always wondered why that is and I
wonder if it has anything to do
with our,
our need for innovation and for growth
and for productivity and if the idea of
like somehow in suppressing sexuality
makes people concentrate on being more
productive and more successful so that
way you can kind of earn sex and if sex
was more free you wouldn't get as much
done.
And I wonder if it's some sort of a
weird work around that.
Almost like I'm the construction of this
advanced civilization as sort of a.
it's like it's,
it's invented this path that sort of
ensures productivity.
And one of the best ways to do that is
to make people compete like in a very,
very efficient and very ferocious way
for the attention of women.
And if this,
the attention of women was easily
achieved,
there would be less ambition and there
would be less.
So in a sense,
suppression like leads to more
materialism that leads to a more obvious
expression of materialism.
Like you want the big house,
you want the Nice Watch,
you want the nice shoes,
nice clothes and in wanting all those
things,
you want to list things because sex is
like difficult to achieve.
And if sex was easy to achieve,
you'd be a little bit more relaxed and
your needs because like ultimately the
physical needs kind of like trump,
all the other stuff,
you know,
I could do you want,
do you want a nice watch?
Yeah,
I mean it's okay.
Why do I want.
And I swatched it will look.
They kind of look cool.
Okay.
But do you want a nice watch?
Because girls are gonna recognize it.
Yeah.
Well girls don't give a shit about a
nice watch.
They just want to suck your Dick.
Wow.
Well fuck that.
Well you've just summarized the argument
of Freud's civilization and its
discontents reality.
Yeah,
that's what he says.
He says,
civilization is the product of a
repressed sexual energy being redirected
into productive activities.
Huh?
Well,
I've sort of reversed it.
I've reversed it.
Almost like civilization is so weird.
Yeah,
right.
Because because it's the result of that
it wants to continue and amplify that
like any system wants to persist.
So because it's the result of that than
there are in built in mechanisms for
perpetuating that cycle of repression.
Redirection,
you know,
dangling the carrot.
I mean if,
if capitalism could stop us from
breathing and then charge us for air,
they would.
And you made this one tweet,
which again,
I think it's fairly innocuous.
I actually know completely innocuous.
Totally justified.
The first tweet the company you were
working for makes in response to it.
They call you,
they're former community leader.
Was that how you found out you were.
You were
fired practically.
So I can run you through the timetable
list if you want.
So,
so at the beginning
of the day,
what company was it again?
Oh,
well,
the company that I worked for is called
Turo rock studios.
A bunch of really talented artists who
are making it an incredibly ambitious
game called evolve.
Um,
and so the game was,
the game is and was and still is really
awesome.
Um,
but the,
the,
the company,
you know,
gain development,
we work in a slightly different clock
than most of corporate America.
We work,
we go in at like 10:00 AM and we leave
at like 7:00 PM because we're usually up
until really late evening,
late in the evening.
So I really don't even wake up until
like 9:00 everyday most days.
So that day I woke up and my phone was
buzzing and blowing up.
Uh,
one of my,
one of my really close friends and
colleagues at the time texted me and he
was like,
Hey,
by the way,
you know that stuff you tweeted about
the other day,
like some news outlet picked up on it,
some small thing and ultra group,
exactly what we wanted to capitalize on
that,
on that,
that sensational headline.
And so he,
he was just giving me a heads up and I
was like,
Oh yeah,
you,
no thanks whatever.
To me at the,
at the time I was like,
whatever,
like I know what the group he did,
I don't want to name the site but,
but I know what they're about.
They do this all the time.
So I was like,
whatever.
Um,
and then so maybe I jumped in the shower
and I get out and I've got texts from
like our gm at our,
at our studio,
like,
you need to go radio dark on all social
media period.
And I was like,
what?
I was like,
And so I texted him back and I'm like,
is this in relation to the article?
The one article that no one else picked
up on and that like,
um,
you know,
half the comments were like that dude,
that's totally not what Josh was saying.
And the other half were kind of reacting
sensationally to it.
But like the other half you've been on
the common to the Oracle,
we're like,
you're taking them out of context.
And that was the entire extent of the
controversy circling me at the time.
Um,
and then 45 minutes later I still have
even left my apartment to go into the
studio yet 45 minutes later my email
stops working and I'm like,
oh,
like,
I'm not dumb,
I'm not stupid.
I'm like,
they literally just shut off my email.
Um,
and then so I tried calling him and he
didn't take my call and then an hour
later he's like,
yeah,
we should,
we should probably meet at like the
starbucks around the corner.
And I was like,
what?
Like you don't even want me to come into
the office and talk about this.
Like you don't want to hear my side of
it,
you don't want to see what's,
what,
like it's just done.
And then they issued the statement that
they made which was like the literally
putting the match to the kerosene.
So maybe there was some kerosene,
maybe there was some potential for
outrage.
And then when they fired me it turned
into this huge thing in the gaming
industry around like,
was that right?
Was that wrong?
So like the,
the vast majority of people who had
never even heard about that or even
would've cared that I tweeted that.
I'm kind of like everybody heard about
it.
Um,
mainstream,
heard about it.
Like Mark Cuban started following me on
twitter.
Like if you were,
if they were afraid the NBA was going to
get pissed at us for me for weighing in
on it,
then you know,
they're kind of reaction to it made it
like 50 times worse.
Yeah.
I wish I was.